[Música]
el gobierno de Venezuela y la oposición
lograron un acuerdo para que dinero
Estatal que está congelado se destine a
gastos humanitarios con la gestión de la
ONU Estados Unidos respondió permitiendo
que la petrolera Chevron vuelva a operar
en suelo venezolano
Se suspendió el paro Cívico que había en
la ciudad boliviana de Santa Cruz de la
sierra y que había comenzado hace 36
días los líderes accedieron a
desbloquear las carreteras de la región
más rica debido a que el congreso Avanza
en el debate sobre el censo poblacional
y Costa Rica jugará el domingo contra
Japón en el mundial de fútbol e
intentará reivindicarse luego de su
derrota frente a los españoles mientras
que la arrojan enfrentará a Alemania en
el Duelo más intenso de la jornada
ampliaremos desde
Bienvenidos a las noticias que Franz 24
dedica a América y también al mundial yo
soy María Clara calle y es un placer
saludarlos y comenzamos hablando de las
noticias relativas a Venezuela porque el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro se reunió el
sábado con la oposición en México y allí
firmaron el segundo acuerdo parcial que
han tenido el nuevo pacto pretende
descongelar entre 2.800 y hasta 5000
millones de dólares que Venezuela tiene
congelados en el sistema financiero
internacional y dedicarlos a acciones
humanitarias Estados Unidos vio con
buenos ojos el acuerdo y en respuesta le
permitió a la petrolera Chevron operar
de nuevo en Venezuela
está de vuelta gobierno y oposición
firmaron un nuevo acuerdo con el que
buscan recuperar recursos del Estado
bloqueados en el sistema financiero
internacional en el acuerdo figura
cooperación en gastos humanitarios como
el pago de proyectos de atención médica
valorados en más de 2700 millones de y
la reparación de redes eléctricas el
presidente Nicolás Maduro lo celebró en
Twitter la firma del segundo acuerdo
parcial entre el gobierno bolivariano
que preside y la plataforma unitaria de
una de las oposiciones abre paso a un
nuevo capítulo para Venezuela en función
de seguir avanzando hacia la paz y el
bienestar que todas y todos los
venezolanos anhelamos Este es el segundo
acuerdo que llega después de que la mesa
de negociación política fuese suspendida
formalmente en octubre de 2021 sin
embargo Venezuela trata de recuperar
activos perdidos e internacionalmente y
aprovechar su posición en un mercado
energético en crisis esto se demuestra
cuando instantes después del anuncio de
la firma entre gobierno y oposición el
departamento del tesoro de Estados
Unidos informó que autoriza a la
petrolera Chevron a retomar operaciones
limitadas de extracción de recursos
naturales esta acción refleja la
política de larga Data de Estados Unidos
de proporcionar un alivio de sanciones
específico basado en pasos concretos que
alivian el sufrimiento del pueblo venezo
y apoyan la restauración de la
Democracia
movimientos que confirman que Venezuela
está de vuelta en el tablero político
internacional
se tensionan más las relaciones entre el
presidente de Perú Pedro castillo y el
congreso el sábado los legisladores
aprobaron interponer una demanda ante el
tribunal constitucional en contra del
mandatario en un intento por anticiparse
a una posible disolución del parlamento
que podría ser castillo y es que el
congreso rechazó esta semana un voto de
confianza que pedía la presidencia para
aprobar un proyecto de ley que pretendía
limitar los referendos cuando los
legisladores lo negaron el ex Primer
Ministro Aníbal Torres renunció y el
gabinete se tuvo que renovar según la
Constitución peruana del presidente
puede disolver el congreso si este
rechaza un voto de confianza en dos
ocasiones a lo que los legisladores
quieren adelantarse yendo al tribunal
para que se pronuncie sobre cómo el
gobierno interpretó el rechazo al voto
de confianza su parte de la presidencia
del poder judicial convocó una sesión
para el domingo en la que se espera que
el presidente Castillo pueda limar
asperezas con el del Congreso con su
presencia y en Bolivia Se suspendió el
paro indefinido que había comenzado
desde hace 36 días en Santa Cruz de la
sierra Los líderes cívicos levantaron
las manifestaciones luego de que el
congreso reactivara un censo que el
presidente Luis Arce había postergado
hasta 2024 la cámara baja Ya aprobó el
proyecto y ahora lo debatirá el senado
si se aprueba la ley le permitiría a la
región más rica de Bolivia tener más
escaños en el legislativo
tras 36 días levantan la huelga en Santa
Cruz de la sierra la cámara de diputados
boliviana decidió que el censo que había
frenado el presidente Luis Arce se
celebrará el 23 de marzo de 2024
[Música]
a la participación a la unidad de
nuestro país y ojalá que hoy
empiecen también a levantarte la medida
de presión que nunca fueron necesarias
la ley fue aprobada por dos tercios de
la cámara baja y fue enviada al senado
para su revisión antes de que sea
promulgada por el presidente Arce el
censo el primero en más de una década
permitirá que los escaños del Congreso
sean redistribuidos antes de las
elecciones generales de 2025
la oposición había acusado al gobierno
de querer retrasarlo ya que el
oficialismo podría salir afectado en las
elecciones generales los líderes de
Santa Cruz anunciaron que aún siguen
pendientes de la completa aprobación de
La Ley a partir de este momento
hacemos un cuarto intermedio
levantamos el paro y bloqueos sin
suspender nuestra lucha seguimos en
emergencia en la región más grande de
Bolivia rica en soya la huelga dejó mil
millones de dólares en pérdidas según el
Ministerio de finanzas Mire ya yo
andaban nervioso ansioso medio Bravo
medio triste Pero por fin hoy una buena
noticia que volvemos a la normalidad los
resultados del censo se entregarán en
septiembre por lo que podrán aspirar
nuevos representantes políticos y
obtener asignaciones económicas para la
región
el desierto de atacama en chile se ha
convertido en un vertedero de basura
Industrial este sitio es ahora un
cementerio de carros viejos y de ropa
nueva o de segunda mano lo que ha creado
un problema ambiental en esta región del
continente
miles de toneladas de desechos en el
desierto de atacama uno de los más
bellos de América del Sur aquí hay
restos de carrocerías por miles y ropa
más allá de donde alcanza la vista
de hecho Esta es una montaña de ropa
solamente que está tapada con tierra
una camisa de Cualquiera podría terminar
aquí porque estas toneladas de prendas
provienen del mundo entero
hay otras que están en perfecto estado
como este vestido fabricado en India
todo constituye una amenaza para el
medio ambiente según está activista
y ahí no preguntarnos
y acá tienes metidas muchas toneladas de
ropa que son un peligro son un riesgo
ambiental son un peligro para la salud
de las personas ya y no corresponde
estos últimos años el desierto de
atacamas se ha llenado de vertidos no
autorizados
chiles especializa en el comercio de
segunda mano
la mercancía llega hasta aquí a través
del puerto de iquique proveniente de
Europa de Asia o de Estados Unidos antes
de ser llevada al mercado chileno o
exportada a los países vecinos salvo una
parte de la mercancía que se queda en el
desierto de atacama abandonada por los
intermediarios el alcalde de una de las
comunas de la región denuncia a la
pasividad del estado es como el patio
trasero ya ni siquiera somos el patio
trasero local sino que somos parte
trasero del mundo que es peor si no hay
conciencia todavía para poder resolver
este problema por el contrario no
chile recibe cada año unas 59 mil
toneladas de ropa y mucha termina
perjudicando el medio ambiente como en
este caso en el desierto de atacama y de
esta situación en el desierto pasamos a
hablar del volcán villarrica ubicado en
el sur de chile que ha aumentado su
actividad arrojando lava y gases las
autoridades emitieron una alerta
amarilla en las regiones vecinas y
declararon una proporción 500 metros
alrededor del cráter como zona de riesgo
Mientras que el servicio nacional de
geología y minería de chile anticipa que
habrá pequeñas explosiones de rocas pero
que no hay un riesgo inminente de
erupción
y cerramos con noticias del mundial de
Qatar Costa Rica es la única selección
latinoamericana que jugará en la jornada
del domingo al medirse frente a Japón y
reponerse de la goleada de 7 a 0 que le
propinó España Canadá por su parte se
enfrentará a Croacia vamos a doha donde
nuestra enviada especial Natalia Ruiz
giraldo nos cuenta lo destacado que
habrá este domingo
este 27 de noviembre es un domingo de
pasión futbolística aquí en Qatar 2022
con cuatro partidos de los grupos e If
será el grupo el que comienza y cierre
esta jornada primero con el Japón Costa
Rica los nipones que vienen crecidos
tras ganarle a Alemania un triunfo
histórico mientras que los ticos pues
tienen que haberse ya levantado de esa
humillación que vivieron ante España y
es precisamente la juventud de la roja
la que va a medirse a la en muy en pleno
renovación de la mensaps Alemania que
está obligada a ganar para seguir
todavía con vida aquí en acatar los dos
otros partidos era el de Bélgica ante
Marruecos los Diablos Rojos que
seguramente van a tener un partido
bastante físico ante los africanos que
hicieron un excelente juego a Croacia la
subcampeona del mundo que a su vez se
enfrentará a Canadá
hasta aquí la información pero ustedes
sigan conectados a France 24
[Música]